Hey youtubers it’s charlie and yesterday
in my trailer breakdown I asked you to submit
all of your game of thrones questions so I
picked 10 with one bonus one.
I will say that the vast majority of the comments
were coldhands and story progression related.
We’re also within two weeks of me beginning
my season 4 countdown series.
So if there’s any special type of video
you want to see in that just let me know.
If you’re finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to join the party.
We have dragons.
Let’s get to the questions.
Careful for spoilers, I’ll try to answer
everything the best I can without being too
explicit.
Number 1 - Alice Cei asks Any chance we see
mention of the next big thing for the House
Targaryen?
I don’t think 10 episodes this season is
enough for that.
I assume you’re talking about the big dance
with dragons plot point.
I think it’s a strong possibility for season
5 depending on where they end season 4.
There are several big moments this season,
so I think Dany or the targaryens or however
you want to think of them, will only get two..
Question 2 - wadjiikhan (no avatar) asks Why
is it that whenever the dragons are shown
its always Drogon in the spotlight?
I like the other 2?
For a couple reasons, mostly because Drogon
is more of a character in the books.
He’s tied specifically to a few really big
moments.
The other dragons have moments too, but Drogon
is like the lead singer of the dragon jam
band.
He’s the biggest and the baddest.
The other reason is just from a cost perspective,
it’s super expensive to do special effects
for a dragon, especially a giant dragon.
So they try to show them as little as possible.
Question 3 - StarPlat 7 asks Where will they
end this season at?
I think it will end on Dany just like season
3, logically the strong moment for them to
end on would be dany and drogon.
If you want to know what that is and you don’t
care about spoilers, read dance with dragons
chapter 52.
Other potential places they could end the
season would be with Jon Snow in dance with
dragons chapter 31 or chapter 69.
To be fair though, those are really towards
the end of the book.
There are several battles and major conflicts
all over westeros and in the east.
Usually each season ends right after a great
victory or great defeat.
So you could pick almost any of the big battles
as an end point.
I don’t think they’ll make it through
all the book 4 and 5 material this season.
Question 4 - Andrew Jones asks Who is the
woman that we see burned during the Melisandre
night fire scene?
A lot of people wondered whether this was
Brienne but it’s not.
I would say it’s a wildling or someone from
Stannis’ own ranks given her age.
Melisandre usually burns someone or something
of significance to provide magical aide to
stannis’ army.
It looks like this happens before they sail
from dragonstone.
Question 5 - andalib nizam asks Why do you
think Arya included Melisandre in her prayer?
Melisandre is the one who took gendry to be
sacrificed.
Remember arya got up in her face and she even
saw a little bit of arya’s future.
It’s a very stabby future.
Question 6 - ariadna quijano asks Shae will
have the same destiny as in the book?
There were a lot of Shae questions, so I’ll
try to answer all of them.
Yes shae will have more scenes, but based
on the way they teased us with the trailer
I think it will play out in a similar manner.
Meaning the end result will be the same, but
shae will get a lot more story than she did
in the books.
Part of the issue with understanding her motivation
in book 4 was that she was barely part of
the story.
I think the show will try to expand on that
to make the why of it all a little more clear.
Question 7 - Muhammad Hasir asks Does Jon
find out about rob?
Or bran?﻿
He learns about the Red Wedding because ravens
were sent everywhere, but he doesn’t know
what happened to Bran.
Pretty much everyone assumes he was killed
by theon because they swapped the bodies when
winterfell was sacked.
Question 8 - Colin Coughtrey asks Do you think
I should read the books, will it improve or
lessen my experience of watching the show?
You should definitely read the books.
They’re just downright awesome.
You don’t have to read them to follow the
show.
But if you like fantasy stories then yes.
If you start now, by the time you finish winds
of winter will probably be finished.
Question 9 - The Warmonger asks Do you think
that the white walker at the end of the trailer
is cold hands?
So time to address all the coldhands questions.
No I don’t think it’s the coldhands from
dance with dragons.
Mostly because coldhands was not a white walker.
And this person looks just like a white walker.
Coldhands looked like a wight, which is a
reanimated corpse.
So he looked more like a zombie.
He also wore a deep hood.
It’s possible that what the show is doing
is giving the cold hands part in the book
to a regular white walker.
They do mix things around a lot on the show,
but I don’t think we can call whoever this
is coldhands.
I think he’s just a random white walker.
Question 10 - Aimee Morris (no avatar) asks
do you think they'll run out of material for
season 5 and have to create new plots that
differ from the books?
Eventually yes, but not in the way you think.
People ask george rr martin and the show runners
this question all the time.
I think that winds of winter will be finished
by the time season 5 gets started next year.
But because they have to write all the stories
6 months ahead of time what will probably
happen is george rr martin will give them
an idea for how he wants the characters to
develop and some logical sign posts for the
plot and the show will just do it’s own
things within those boundaries.
So by the time we get to season 6, they’ll
go way off book.
Because dream of spring probably won’t be
done until 2018 or 2019 given how long it
took to write winds of winter.
In interviews martin has also said that he
considers the show to have it’s own canon
that’s unique from what he’s done in the
books or what he’s getting ready to do.
Bonus Question - footylova4evaa asks Did you
come across the books or tv show first?
I learned about the books in 2007, so I read
the first four books over the course of a
year or two and then waited till 2011 for
dance with dragons.
And I haven’t re-read them since.
I will refer to specific chapters if there’s
a question about a plot point though.
But it’s been a couple years since i’ve
read them.
Thanks so much for submitting questions everyone.
This was a lot of fun like always.
Unless they announce a new trailer or special
new footage for me to break down my next game
of thrones video will probably be my top 5
favorite characters from season 3.
Like i said, my big countdown series will
start in about two weeks.
And it will have all kinds of different videos.
Think of it as like when I did all the doctor
who videos around the 50th anniversary episode.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
Right now click here for all my season 4 breakdowns
and click here for my walking dead episode
10 review.
We finally found out what happened to baby
judith.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!